we are getting more details tonight on
how covid-19 measures at our borders and
our airports will soon change Global
News has learned the Prime Minister has
given the green light to drop the
mandatory covid-19 vaccination
requirements to enter the country at the
end of this month while this news will
most certainly help Travelers who have
been stuck in Long airport or land
Border Lines the impact will also help
professional sports leagues return to
normal with new NHL and NBA Seasons
right around the corner pro sports teams
in North America have had to deal with
numerous issues throughout the covid-19
pandemic I think it's really good to see
come back from a normal summer again and
hopefully we get through this winter and
well we have a little
a bit of
back to normal
it's good to see everybody no mask
Toronto Raptors and blue jays had to
relocate South of the Border in 2021
when restrictions were much tighter when
the Canada U.S border reopened those who
weren't vaccinated for covet were
suddenly on the outside looking in
headlines were made this past July when
the Kansas City Royals had to leave 10
players who weren't vaccinated behind in
the U.S we hear about Canada's border
regulations and how tough Canada is it's
exactly the same in the United States so
if the Blue Jays had unvaccinated
players which they don't the full roster
is fully vaccinated but if they had
unvaccinated players they would have to
play only Road games no it's not really
just a good look you know MLB wants a
good product in the field and uh you
know a lot of the star players aren't
playing but you know it's a decision
they made ironically one of those
players Whit Merrifield was later traded
to the Blue Jays and he chose to take
the vaccine so he could play at home
with his new team in the NHL Detroit Red
Wing Tyler
remained unvaccinated last season
playing only games against U.S teams and
missing games on the road that were
played in Canada in the NBA Brooklyn
netstar Kyrie Irving missed the first 35
games of last season with the state of
New York having a vaccine policy that
wouldn't allow the unvaccinated Irving
to play in a public venue it's not
always about the money it's about
choosing what's best for you you think I
really want to lose money
you think I really want to give up on my
dream to go after a championship
you think I really just want to give up
my job the state would eventually drop
its mandates and Irving would return to
play at home but the criticism from the
disruption continues for the Nets who
suffered an early round playoff exit
last season with Canada looking like it
will drop its mandates all eyes will be
on the Biden Administration to see if
they'll follow suit but it hasn't always
been border restrictions that have
caused a stir when it came to vaccine
mandates in sports stars NFL star Aaron
Rodgers vaccination status became a Hot
Topic after the quarterback voiced his
opinion on vaccines last summer calling
it a personal decision when asked by the
media if he was vaccinated Rogers says
he was immunized against coven 19. after
news broke that Rogers tested positive
for covid last November his vaccination
status once again came under scrutiny he
clarified that he had undergone his own
protocols to protect himself from coven
and denied he had lied to the media but
Rogers has recently admitted that he did
indeed mislead the media and the public
on his vaccination status tennis star
Novak djokovic's conflict with the
Australian government over whether he
should have been allowed to play in
January's Australian Open serves as one
of the more highly publicized battles an
athlete has waged over covid-19 vaccine
mandates Djokovic who was not vaccinated
against coven had initially been granted
an exemption to compete but his Visa was
revoked upon his arrival in Melbourne
and he was held in an immigration
detention for several days he was later
released when a judge ruled the
cancellation of the Visa was
unreasonable because the player was not
given time to consult with lawyers and
Tennis officials when he arrived in the
country good evening we begin with
breaking news and Novak Djokovic has
lost his appeal and will be deported the
native of Serbia was also issued a
three-year ban from entering the country
but government sources have recently
told local media out Outlets that
Djokovic could be allowed into the
country for the next Grand Slam
Tournament in January for Global News
I'm Steve audio